announ Maybe
right uh good morning so welcome to uh
day number four of our second Workshop
of this uh logic and algorithms program
and um before we begin today uh I would
like to kind of remind you of why we're
here so um you know this Workshop is on
uh logic and algorithms and find when
complexity in query evaluation
and um there's obviously a lot in in
common and uh the general picture uh is
something like this so we have data
stored in a database like you know a
graph uh we have queries that are issued
into the database and we would like to
answer the query as quickly as
possible uh the question of how uh is
typically answered with some kind of
fine R complexity analysis so that's why
there you know the fine R complexity
part of the
workshop um the the language that is
used to express the query is typically
logic so that's the logic part of the
workshop right um and then uh sometimes
uh the answer to a query is actually not
what we want sometimes we do some
computation on top of this answer of
this query and that that was uh you know
uh Q2 and uh in uh day one we um talked
about non-recursive queries so mostly uh
like triangles or something and then on
top of that we would like to enumerate
um the you know every two pole in the
answer one by one with constant delay
enumeration uh in uh day two uh there
was um the relational programming
Paradigm when we do some kind of uh
query uh on top of the output of the in
of of the query and uh that could be
like training a machine learning model
um and so
on um day three was about how best to
answer this query with um distributive
computation that was
yesterday and uh today we are moving on
a little bit to uh recursive query so
this is a second you know class of
queries we have not looked into um and
then uh tomorrow uh I guess that'll be
day
five um we'll think about uh there'll be
a presentation on how do you do this
when there's an update to the database
uh we're not going to recompute the
whole thing you know how best to to
compute the answer uh if you knew the
answer to the previous version of the
database okay uh so um so that's kind of
you know just uh just want to sync up so
that we don't get lost in in the
technical presentations so without
further Ado I will um start today with
Ry Wang uh who is now an assistant
professor at UCL
and he is on one of our fellows I um
will give the mic to
Remy okay checking this uh can people
hear me okay thank you and let me find
the
marker and is it okay if I erase the
part
yeah
okay so uh my talk has two parts and
then the plan is that for the first part
I'll talk about uh uh actually still in
the non-recursive case right before we
recurse we have to think about a base
case so still in the non- recursive case
uh but in general how do we make any
program run fast so talking about uh the
idea of program optimization as
sech and then uh to understand the big
picture so uh the the goal of program
automization is that you give me a input
program so here is your slow
program in some programming language uh
just think of any arbitrary you know to
complete language or to not complete
language for for example C++ right and
and now let's think of this entire
whiteboard so this piece of whiteboard
as a space of all programs you can write
in this language and some of these are
slow so this one this is the one that
you gave me so this is probably not opal
program so our goal uh is to find from
this space
uh a fer
program that has a property that uh is
the same it behaves the same as your St
program so what that means is that for
all inputs uh we're going to produce the
same output
uh at order program right so so that's
really the the you know mes high level
of uh uh
programation so this is a challenging
just just like in any combinatorial
search uh so we have a huge search space
so this search space contains the
program we have as input the the program
we want and it also has other programs
like some programs that are
slower and then it also has program that
run faster but it's actually wrong right
so we have uh wrong
programs so the challenge is really to
uh kind of explore this huge surface in
order to find a program that's both
correct uh and fast so our approach uh
this is work done with my cabber Max in
audience here is that we uh explore only
part of the search Bas so in in
particular we only explore uh the
programs that are uh correct so we only
export a search space that covers all of
the uh the equivalent space of the
program so this will be a Subspace of
the entire search
space right and then basically uh we
Traverse this space uh by rewriting the
program to to each other so uh if we
think of maybe the the talk by Mahmud a
few days ago uh so we s uh we saw that
we have this algebra Expressions these
some product Expressions uh and then by
doing some algebraic rewriting so maybe
pushing the summation inside of
multiplication and and uh uh and addings
uh so we can make the program faster uh
just by doing these rewritings so the
idea is the same here so we start with
the input program and then in general we
will apply these rewritings to get to
the faster
one uh and then so the first challenge
here is that we want to uh somehow
represent this search space efficiently
right uh so in general this search space
this space of e programs it can be
infinite there can be infl many programs
that is uh uh that are equivalent to the
input uh so we want to represent as much
as this space as possible uh so the idea
is that yes quick question I was
thinking because you talked about wrong
programs is there any reason to look at
them other than for approximation like
if you think of approximation as the
wrong answer yeah so uh so there is
another approach uh of kind of going at
this program optimization problem is
that naively we think about enumerating
all the program that run faster than
this one until we find find the correct
one right so that's kind of a or oral
Sur space and in here we only explored
the equal ones and to find a faster one
the other one would be even harder right
because you would have to decide if
they're equivalent which is that's right
yeah uh yeah it's not possible in
General but in some cases uh we can do
that yeah so that part uh in in
programming languages there's been a uh
a pretty popular approach program
synthesis and that's basically what they
do so they they try out different
problem programs until they find the
correct one and sounds crazy but it kind
of works
yeah okay uh yeah so back to the problem
of representing this search bace and by
the way ask as many questions as
possible uh I want to uh make this
interactive and also ask you questions
um so the approach we take is that we
represent the search space with a tree
automaton so I find say three autom and
then so Marcelo yes before you run the
search uh how do you know that the
search time is less than the time it
takes to just run Ah that's a uh good
point so sometimes uh we don't care so
sometimes we know that we we'll run this
program again and again and again so
it's better to spend more time
optimizing it uh sometimes uh we do have
a budget of how long we want to uh
explore faster programs before we
realize oh we're spending more time than
actually running
it yeah so for the moment let's just
assume that the compile time doesn't
matter so we can spend as much time as
we want in compilation and
onization okay so tree autometer uh so
Marcelo told us a little bit really
quickly about tree automa when he uh
talk about the uh sampling and then here
let's do a slower introduction right
so uh so tree autometa they are a
generalization of the final string
autometer uh and then uh it's actually
pretty similar so before talking about
autom uh let's talk talk about trees so
the trees we care about here uh are
basically directed with directed addes
and label nodes so only the nodes are
are labeled uh and then the Eds are not
labeled and then for each label we also
have a fix arity so in other words we
can think of these trees as kind of a
terms in a in a given grammar so here's
one example we just have uh the
multiplication and then one child is
constant a one constant B right so here
all of the inputs we think of them you
can think of as constants variables so
these are zero function symbols there a
zero add function symbol and here's a
binary function right so whenever we see
multiply we must also see two
to so that's the kind of trees we're
we're dealing with um and uh so okay so
uh what's a tree automatan so tree
Automan basically
defines a set of trees so accept a set
of trees just like a string automatan
accept a set of strings uh and then uh
so it also consists of States so we have
a
uh a set of
states and then we also have a a set of
transitions uh so I think usually there
written
DOTA So within the set of States uh we
can distinguish a few States uh usually
just one uh so let's just we have one
single fi accepting state or final state
so s uh a
accepting
and then the one difference between uh
tree automatan and string automat is
that we don't have a St state so instead
we're going to have a transition
function uh that transition from nothing
right so we're kind of a without the
input with transition for state
so yeah and then for other transition
functions uh each transition function
can transition from a from multiple
state to a new state so in general uh
every trans position uh takes a set uh a
two pole of of
States uh
S1
S2 and then we see a function symbol
some f and then transition to another uh
one single uh Target State like
this and uh just to make this concrete
uh what what what the semantic of this
is so let's look at a few examples right
so if I if I tell you this we have a
transition function that transition from
nothing to
uh to the accepting
State seeing the function symbol a so if
we just say that this is the tree
automon we're dealing with so can
someone tell me what uh uh what trees do
this
accept just single node labeled a yeah
it just just a right so uh similarly if
we had have
just a transition from uh from
B well from nothing via B to S of
B so this aomin over here with just just
this one single transition it it will
accept the Tre this literally just this
little constant B over
here uh so now a question to you is that
how can we what more do we need for this
autom to to accept exactly this tree
here I I need to add one more transition
over here for it to
happen okay I
guess yeah so it's going to be uh a
transition that uh it's going to be a
hyper Edge because there a transition
from two say simultanous so we need to
be in both sa and SB uh and then we
transition uh through uh this is
multiply to
the right so here in general we can see
that we can we can turn any tree into a
aom that accepts exactly that tree
pretty easily so we just turn every
single leaf node into a transition uh
from empty through that node into some
State uh and then at every Edge we
simply add a transition so at every
internal node we add add a transition
that goes from the other nodes as stats
into that node yeah ification uh is
there an accepting State on the board
right now if not is capital A a bug yeah
that's right so uh so this uh is should
be little
a
and then so if we want to accept uh this
tree then the accepting Stace needs to
be uh this guy over
here any any more questions or the same
question but also do you have like
Epsilon transitions where let's say if
you need multiple accepting States you
just do a trick you put them all into
one yeah we can have them uh for this
talk it doesn't matter so we can't
ignore those
yeah okay so right now our automaton is
not very interesting so it only accepts
uh one single tree uh so let's make it a
little more uh interesting right so I'm
G to make it uh into a larger tree first
uh so let's say we have this tree right
so we have a times uh B and divide it by
B right and then so here the first uh
first interesting thing we can do is
that now we can have a little bit of of
sharing your your
Automan so in order to accept this tree
we don't have to make another state uh
for for B right so we can reuse this
state uh and then what we do is that
now after uh we transition to the state
for x uh state for for multiply and then
the state for for B uh we can add
another transition into this division
note uh so let
me
this excuse me you the as
ordered yes
is it then okay to to
reuse I guess what do you mean by
ordered okay okay like left to right
does it matter yeah it does matter so so
uh yeah so a a times B uh is not Auto or
no this divided by B is not the same as
B divided by
that yeah so re reusing is also okay so
here
okay so uh after this uh remember we
want to optimize programs right so here
we still have one single tree so it's
not very interesting so to make it more
interesting we're going to start adding
more programs into this automaton uh to
represent a larger space uh so you know
one one basic rle we can say that is
that so if we have uh uh if we know B is
equal to
two uh
let so let me just change B into two all
over the
place for
confusion one
more thank
you so if we know uh B is equal to two
then uh a * two can can be Rewritten
into a left shift by one right so we
have another
node over here which is uh s of uh I
don't know left shift uh and then we
have another
one that accepts the number
one uh and then we can go to
here uh and then to represent that these
two are equivalent so we can just merge
these two states where uh as uh uh I
think uh uh audience suggested before we
added a Epsilon transition in between
those States so here I'm just going to
merge the two
states so at this point one important
thing to not is that now now our our
states are representing equivalence
classes of Expressions so here we
basically say that this state will will
accept uh two different trees so one is
a * two and the other one is a left than
one so they are both accepted by by this
St because they are equalent to each
other so that's the uh the key thing
here and then if we do go one more step
so we know that if something times
another thing and then we divide it by
the same thing then we uh assuming
division by zero doesn't exist uh then
we can merge this state with a itself as
well right so let's make it a
little complicated so over here we also
have there one point
here yeah so now we have a a rather
complicated automon uh and then the cool
thing to noce that now we're
representing actually infinite number of
programs within this automet right
because we can start from here uh and
then we can multiply by two divide by
two and we go back here and then we
multiply by two and divide by two many
many times
right state so here the accepting States
uh it used to be uh the state I just
deleted over here and because I I merge
it with uh the uh the a state so now the
exit is over
here
yeah yeah so that's really a really
small picture of how we How We Do
program optimization using this tree
automaton idea so the uh the process is
really simple it just exactly like how
you plant trees so we first seed with a
a one single tree right so we insert
this one second tree into automaton to
get automaton that accepts exactly that
tree so that's set
one and then step two is that we're
going to to uh grow this tree into a
first uh
metaphorically uh by applying ruales
into the automaton onto the automaton so
so that it represents more and more uh
programs in it so after a while after we
apply this uh maybe the automa was will
stop changing so that means we we reach
so-call saturation uh or maybe we decide
that oh this is good enough so we have
explore as many terms as we want and
then we we run out of time run out of
space so after a while uh we decide to
stop uh and then at the end of this
process we basically have autom that
represents a huge space of program like
we we have here so maybe it's not all of
the programs equal into the input but
we're covering a Prett good space yeah
so about the intuition of a state is
that basically each state is a unique
like arithmetic expression that's not
equivalent to any other so all the
equivalent arithmetic expressions are in
the same state yes yes yes yeah so all
of the equ sub expressions are accepted
by by the same state so far we're going
to break that in a bit uh but for the
final State important point is that this
final state only accepts all other
programs that are equivalent to the
original program so there was another
way to compute a like in a more
complicated way that to that same s a
state that's right that's right yeah as
we see here right so a Times 2ide by two
is the same state as just returning
as
this okay uh so this part is the problem
of uh of representing the the space uh
but we're still not done yet right so we
it's it's cool that we can represent
space but we still need to get out this
faster program uh that that we know uh
is equivalent to the input so that's
basically the the second part uh of this
technique uh so this kind technique uh
the keyword to search for is equality
saturation
so yeah and then so after this talk I'll
also send a list of references of papers
people can look
into so um is there a possibility of
comor
osion that's right yeah so as as we do
this uh so although the the automat
really compactly represents many
programs we still have a chance of you
know exploding the uh the automatan as
we apply so so the the key thing to
remember is that every state represents
one equalness uh class but if we have
just have exponential number of equ
classes then that will get get us in
trouble so one example is that uh if we
have a long chain of multiplies and then
multiply as community and associative
and if we just apply stivity and
commutativity kind of blindly we're
going to end up representing the
exponential number of permutations of
this uh chain
multiplication uh yeah so even though we
have compression is not kind of Magic
Bullet uh so that's one of the the
problems we're trying to solve which is
uh what happens when we do explode and
then I will talk a little bit about that
at the at the end of this
part but that could only happen if you
have a loop right like a recursive call
uh uh not quite so even if we just have
a have a long chain of like a times B
time c times D times C so if we have uh
if we multiply like 10 numbers together
uh then they're like two to the T at
least two to the 10 number of ways to to
multiply so if we represent all of them
then we're going to have exponentially
in many
classes yeah so as actually as an
exercise let's try to do that in the
after so let's explode the the board in
the
aent okay uh so the second part is
exraction uh
and oper
this so just to uh make the intuition
simpler uh we can think about the
different problem so the problem we're
dealing with here is that we have this
automaton representing a different
number of trees and then we want to find
uh maybe the shortest tree uh the
smallest tree in some sense or the tree
with the best cost in some sense so
maybe it's easier in the string case so
let us work with maybe a string automon
and then our goal is to find uh the
shortest string accepted by
autom so let me just give you a random
uh fin
autometer so have start dat over
here
and then make
it yeah so here's a uh string automaton
and then a excepts bunch of strings so
we have a d a number of and number e
followed by D and then b c uh uh I guess
here's
F and so on so forth right uh yes so do
we always want the shortest tree The
Operators don't matter yeah so uh we we
we can as assign cost to the tree yeah
so similar here let's say that you know
a has cost one and B has cost cost two
CS cost three etc etc right and then if
we want to find the cheapest uh the
cheapest string which is you know the
string where the letters add up to the
same the lowest cost uh can someone
guess what algorithm we can use to get
that PA sh this path yeah so really uh
you know if we have find a path uh with
the smallest weight we we treat this as
a graph from the accepting state to the
final state then that string basically
has the length of that path uh and then
in other words if we want to find the
the uh the cheapest string from this
automatan we can we can use something
like d algorithm to get M logm speed for
expression that's making a linearity
assumption that I don't think would hold
in a lot of cases though right uh for
for programs in general
right these Expressions work ah yes uh
yes so so so that's true right so here
we have a constant cost per operator
right so that's that's indeed a simp
simplification uh so uh yeah so let's
look at a general case so first of all
we so strings are basically just uh
unary functions and if we look at
General programs we have uh functions
with different arties and this things
get get a little interesting right so
let's go back uh yeah that's a little
messy so let me make a new new autom
over
here so
uh see yeah I'm gonna go bottom up
because it's a little more intuitive so
say we have
a
and I'll leave follow the symbols uh
because they're not very important uh
and then the key is that we want to find
some kind of
sharing uh it's going to be
right
right so now we have a have a Tre atom
and then the ination is kind of the same
right so if we want to find uh uh so
actually this is still not very
interesting because we don't have
sharing yet so let me point this to
here
yeah so we have a uh tree automaton that
accepts uh basically two different trees
so we have a choice between going here
and going here uh uh in the tomon and
then if we want to find the cheapest
tree we basically want to find the
cheapest hyper path uh from the final
accessing State uh to a bunch of Le Leaf
noes right so
uh for this for this case if we treat
the cost as you know the total cost as a
tree so uh if we have some some more
sharing uh let's see so if we have uh uh
this one over
here a little more
sharing so if we take a lab path and
then we double count the cost of each
each occurrence of a and each Curr B uh
there is actually a m log in
algorithm
uh uh to do this extraction process to
find a certain path uh and then this is
uh actually discovered by described by
Donald Cruz uh in 70 uh three I
think yeah so I will I send a link in
the in the SL uh and then this is
basically what we implement or what Max
Implement in the in our Tool uh so the
idea is that we're going to assign
initially infinite cost to every node uh
and then we'll try to uh find a lower
and lower bound until until it converges
right so this is
a called the generalization of D
algorithm so the connection to the short
PR problem is very apparent so that's an
easy case if we treat you know each
duplicate uh uh node in the in the three
weeks
uh as separate cost right so more
interesting case that sometimes we
extract uh the final program as a deck
which means that if we have sharing if
if we reuse a node then we're gonna only
compute that node once so we have a a de
of a tree as the compute graph so in
that case uh we I think have preliminary
proof that this extraction problem is
actually now becomes MP hard right so it
went from mlogin into MP heart
so
see yeah so really uh the shorty p uh
idea is that we start from the the top
node accepting node and then uh we we're
going to move to all children
simultaneously so from here we go to
here and from here we have to either
move to this two children or to these
two children uh and then eventually uh
we need to up all the path and they
either repeat share noes or not repeat
share noes to find the uh the cost so
this should be 7even
77 okay so it's NPR so uh some earlier
papers uh had the idea of maybe can we
encode this as interum program right so
we have a few constraints so uh one
constraint
is
uh first we have to uh pick the final
state so the B is a bu variable assigned
to every state uh and transition symbol
so we have to uh pick the final State uh
and then we have two more constraints we
have uh for all the uh uh all the
function symbols F transition F we need
to decide if we want to pick or not and
then for all each state s we need to
decide what or not to pick it so the F
and S are designed are defined as
follows so if we see a function symbol F
we see that if we pick the function
symbol then we have to uh pick all of
its
arguments
um
have to pick all these argument States
and then so if we pick a
state then we have to uh make a choice
of which uh which child of that state we
want to also
pick and under this constraints
uh we want to
minimize uh the total cost uh assigned
to assigned to the the function symbols
right so here still we we have this
Assumption of every function symbol has
a constant cost so uh to get over that
uh that's on going work right so so does
this make sense to
people okay good so that's wrong uh
let's let's look at why that's wrong
right so if we look at uh where did our
uh if we look at just this simple
automaton right so we have
uh position do to
this and then we have another one and we
have a loop over here
right and then finally we have
accept right so our our constraint says
that we have to pick the final state so
we have we pick this one and then if we
pick a state we have to pick uh one of
these children so here we have one
choice so we're going to pick this
one so if we pick a transition we have
to pick all of the children so once
again we have one single choice so we'll
pick this one and then now now it's
where it get gets interesting right so
this this state uh has two transitions
that go to it so we can either pick the
F or pick the B so let's suppose we pick
F
right and then here because we enter the
loop then we can kind of satisfy all our
constraints without being grounded and
this is not valid program because it
doesn't really take any input right it
just say F applied to itself and to
nothing right so in fact if we just do
this uh do this uh this uh into ILP we
will get invalid programs and it
actually took us a while to find this SP
right so uh the answer uh is actually in
logic programming so instead of inte
integer in linear program we actually
needed to encode this as a answer set
program uh so I think so this this is
really the ex example that taught me the
difference between uh IOP and ASP
so
uh yes can we fix the linear program by
adding uh like a
depth value that is associated with
every yeah so that's one fix uh but in
in practice that kind of run really
slowly so you can you can basically
order the nodes in in some way yeah so
that we always the depth of a new node
is higher than the dep of if it's a
children and that how that's how we
can yeah so that's one that's a correct
fix but it runs kind of slowly
yeah yeah so uh this is a very quick
introduction to an programming and let
me see oh I'm already out of time is
that is that right for the first part
for the first part a little break sure
yeah this is a good good place to stop
um and then yeah let's come back to the
SP after the
break so we have a 5 minut
break
to do some